let's go gamers you know the game just
don't laugh it's that simple
come on how many episodes have I done of
this Jesus Christ it's the show that
never dies
I'm just 65 that's not too bad listen
everyone complain I will keep wearing my
glasses I Lydia I can't see I'm blind I
read a comment saying he's addicted to
his glasses I need all right here we go
that's too sexy come on that waste of my
time I wanna live not lose I mean the
opposite of that almost had me
goddammit go ahead you can do it come on
hilarious
I know I lost I don't care I'm in the
mood to laugh it doesn't matter okay we
have carrot though you put that I don't
understand how this works does it
actually work like that yeah it's like
the ramen thing how how did sorry but
how does it come orange how I make
orange out of nuts so confused he
spray-painted it is that what it did can
you spray orange oh my god the effort
Jesus Christ
ahh bra no what is that he can't just do
that see I feel like he goes from zero
to 100 really quick there can you really
do that I'm so good I want to try that
can someone else do that cuz I don't
have the effort to try that mr. Bies
come on I would love to have a chair
like that and just tell people that come
over here please have a seat
tell them to sit in the chair and they
just start giggling and be like what
what's so funny and we're like you
wouldn't get it sorry
how n-words in Iraq go grocery shopping
yeah I've seen this with a different
caption but it's European village it's
not freaking Iraq okay
I know from the European sign hence why
I don't play Modern Warfare anymore
great hey remember the video I did we
might say where we played our chair of
the game is now updating with six new
heroes they all have different strengths
and different skills hilux that sounds
like me i made it to the crystal mines
level 43 see if you can beat it i
actually got really hooked on this game
after I did that promo they know how new
daily events where you can survive it
through specific dungeons and collect
resources for progression download
Archer today you won't regret it it's
super fun
I clearly suck at it now my high ass
scooping up mashed potatoes on
not gonna lie he straight-up vibing
though come on yeah come on that [ __ ]
slime don't lie have you left yet
don't laugh that's the rule of the game
rule of game is no ha ha you life you
leave how about that yeah go bye-bye
please keep watching please please I
have more funny videos I'm sure look at
this one that's so wholesome now I feel
like watching loded thanks me too so
nice I can't up can we have a remake of
Lord of the Rings with cats I don't even
like cats but that would be awesome I'm
so tired I'm it's so late I have to
record an extra video but I think it
works out well because I'm so giggly
except it doesn't work at well because
I'm not to put the left it's ok I've
punished myself me on the way to the
first day of a class trying to think of
three phones thanks so seriously
the caption is so relatable and so is
the video I feel like the caption makes
me laugh for more than that it says why
do i hey I don't have three fun facts
about myself
does anyone have 3 fact fun fact about
herself huh what are you always had to
pull that out of nowhere I'm like at
least at tell me before so the day
before I can prepare and be like ok 3
fan facts are by myself 1 this is the
problem pretty fun facts about yourself
tell me tell me I'm listening that's
right you got nothing don't even try
this is someone dying while having an
MRI scan before you die your brain
releases tons and tons of endorphins
number one pose in tumblr history this
is a Jeff my time a jet or of someone
turning into it yeah it's from walking
bed isn't it from look at that I'm done
with this stupid website by stupid
website tumblr I want to see the actual
reblogs of this how many people reblog
this it's like that movie what does it
call seven pounds seven pounds leaves
your body when you died there
there is a soul when you touch the
coffeepot and is high that's an awfully
hot coffee pot that's an awfully hot
coffee pot okay
true true not gonna lie
Eminem is spreading straight facts over
here you gonna drop it again I try I
feel like it is dope what he did but
that the whole context and the start
just completely ruin it for me there's
an awfully hard copy I don't hate it I
love him in him okay don't get me wrong
but like he kinda took an L on that one
me pressing no when the card machine
asked if I want to donate my change to
starving children oh boy I swallow that
laugh I swallow it at 87 years of age
this cyclist is this the new format of
all memes on Instagram just a caption I
know it's a tweet this cyclist is an
inspiration asia's is a number listen
we're all gonna die at some point come
on it's fine at least he died doing what
he loves all right how resonant
frequencies no that's witchcraft
that's definitely witchcraft okay this
is a tutorial on how to determine the
resonant frequency of an object oh
you're not gonna do the cool water thing
don't waste my time
all right be honest have you scratch
that yet be honest be honest I remove
glasses do you have to honest now I'm
blind now I can't laugh oh that's smart
actually
[Music]
please tell me here but let's go no I
did not
I don't wanna laugh at that that's
horrible dee dee dee dee dee dee dee
this is cringe I'm just like really I'm
out of it okay that one I could resist I
could resist I even though that is funny
don't laugh feelings it's like I know
I'm not supposed to laugh which makes it
somewhat harder okay okay gamers it's
hard it's hard oh here it is again
alright that's an awfully hot coffee pot
this is a meme now there's an awfully
hot coffee pot did I Jeffrey Epstein
kill himself probably not that's a great
meme brah come on Tobey Maguire you can
do it
guess not we need tobe a spider-man
again I miss him
this is a half-life sound I thought it
was minecraft for a second yeah I didn't
got that it's clever but I didn't write
that just so we're clear yes but what
would happen if for some reason we
ignore somebody unlocked 100 percent of
the cerebral capacity but terrible
acting yes but what would happen if we
ignore is cerebral capacity and then the
con dude British Center you can have me
acting in there
yes but Morgan Freeman what would happen
somebody unlocked 100 percent of the
cerebral kappa 100% 100% yes I see this
yes yeah you made the spoof I use the
spoon to make this food bruh this is the
channel that's gonna beat me in the
future it's five minutes crap
61 million subscribers I know I'm not
bad I'm not battered but man at least
I'm not making poon tutorials hi
imagine making this out ironically I get
sad tired that it has to be sorry sir it
but do you have a bad actually this is
false because if you use the reverse
card it just goes back to your turn
boomers I know boomers are watching I
have the demographic okay thirty percent
of my audience to stop watching this
video please come back boomers I'd love
to well this is one of those jumping
spiders we have those in Japan they're
kind of cute actually oh hey you died
hey hey they're cute though here in UK
they're just awful I still think about
Japan everything is cute in Japan even
the spiders are adorable those are cute
I wouldn't mind if that jumped on me oh
[Music]
it's keemstar god damn ahead I'm so this
is the war I'd suppose I've ever laughed
at are you life awaits this is why we
need face filters for dogs and cats I
was so funny
[Laughter]
Church yes
well what a fashion icon Kanye is look
at that blue shirt he's wearing like
damn how does he do it
how is Kanye's such an icon I don't get
it hey what's a seven special arias
can't Ali funny or cringe or even
tensional damn well play what happened
[Laughter]
wait I keep looking right and I'm
distracted by whatever the hell what is
this thumbnail
what is that thumbnail that's my
thumbnail now my my thumbnail what
animal is that no don't be none the
berries
[Music]
No
well I still enjoy this you laughs you
lose check out another your life you
lose hope you guys enjoyed this one
smash like subscribe see you tomorrow
bye bye hey door hey hey stop you
haven't bought the pity pie figurine
limited time only $29.99 and that's a
great price
[Music]